gary um
you've made a lot of money in nfts
and i've lost a lot of money in crypto
really yeah it makes sense based on our
talents thank you
good way to start starting off
uh
explain to me why nfts aren't [ __ ]
um
they aren't [ __ ] because
a lot of the act let's actually ask why
did you ask that question yes
it's because
when new things come along there's an
incredible opportunity for [ __ ] okay
when things are
very complicated and hard to understand
it creates an opportunity for hucksters
to take advantage
uh and there's all versions of hucksters
we have the instagram
social media club promotion entrepreneur
huckster of this generation now that is
very prominent nfts when internet was
the last time we saw this big of
technology happened the hucksters
were actually
harvard business school wall street
uh
madison avenue established executives
and
and ironically and this is important i
actually don't think that every one of
them understands that they're doing
[ __ ] behavior
here's what happens in a gold rush
gold rush behavior
the reason it's [ __ ] is people see
the money and it's so big
that consciously or subconsciously
they don't even realize they're doing
[ __ ] for example there are
absolutely people who've launched a 10
000 pfp project copying board ape
copying vfriends copying crypto punks
who literally are sitting in the room
right now and think that they are
remarkable artists
that they are incredibly good [ __ ] that
[ __ ] that they're gonna build the next
teenage mutant ninja turtles they're
completely confident
they're gonna launch it
it's gonna sell a bunch of [ __ ]
people are gonna buy a squirrel with a
taco up its ass for four thousand
dollars as a image right it's not a jpeg
you're already on that it's not a jpeg
you're on that right yeah it's not a
jpeg because it's not on the internet
it's an nft because it's on the
blockchain lots of people got jokes in
the comments and social yeah completely
based on the fact that they don't know
what the [ __ ] they're talking about yeah
and it's not it's not a jpeg it's not a
jpeg it is also a jpeg it for you for
everything you know what i'm saying of
course i do like a rectangle's a square
or whatever that is most correct
one or the other you know the name like
squares a rectangle rectangle is a
square you know we're talking about nfts
here is not a square yeah
[Music]
you guys are remarkable communicators
pure escapism and entertainment grounded
in stupid i did pick up on that
all right thank you all right it's true
this is how you're winning
um
you i understand you're pretending to
know how to tease i'm looking at liquid
death because i have a comp on what
liquid death did in its category yeah
like
50 years ago somebody rolled up on other
people and said i'm going to sell water
and water was free in the faucet and
everyone laughed the [ __ ] out of them
yeah it was the stupidest idea of all
time in 1957 62 somebody said i'm gonna
sell bottled water i'm gonna charge for
water and every [ __ ] person on earth
said you're a [ __ ] idiot it's free
out of everyone's faucet isn't that just
people in like the first world where
it's clean oh my god like in the third
world like selling water was the [ __ ] i
was like
in reverse while we take a public
service announcement everyone should go
to charity water and donate a couple of
bucks because there's still 850 million
people on [ __ ] earth that don't have
access to clean water but do they have
nfts they probably don't maybe we should
give them nfts maybe that's how you
solve the problem maybe we give them
both okay you know the world likes to
think an ore i like to think an ant
wow we're dropping time
people take these sentences and use them
in different ways yeah we are listen i
think that i understand why people think
it's a jpeg everyone's bringing their
internet brain to the blockchain just
like everybody brought their real word
real world brain to the internet in 1996
which is why people didn't see it when i
launched winelibrary.com for my dad
everybody told me nobody would buy
anything on the internet i told them
people are going to buy wine on the
internet when we got into debates i told
them people were going to buy tomatoes
on the internet which for some reason in
the 90s set people off because everybody
thought you had to touch tomatoes in the
market and then fresh direct did its
thing boom so
i think that people are struggling
because they don't know what they're
talking about yes when a jpeg on the
internet is not owned by anything
because it's centralized thus you don't
own it on the blockchain it's
decentralized the ledger shows that you
own it and that
jpeg slash nft can do [ __ ]
what it does is based on the execution
liquid death in a remarkably crowded
market of bottled beverage
hit in the last seven years yeah
99
of the liquid death
decks that came through my inbox to
invest in go to zero
one percent hit
99 of streetwear brands don't hit kith
hit like
99 of nft projects are gonna be garbage
do you know how many teenage mutant
ninja turtle attempts there's been 40
billion but that one hit right marvel
hit batman hit but there's a [ __ ] load
of [ __ ] that didn't it took [ __ ]
black panther 40 years to hit so it's
not nfts it's crypto punks or board
absolutely good nfps in the macro are
100 the technology's too big
the individual projects within them yes
it's like saying social media doesn't
work no it doesn't work for you because
you're not charismatic smart or
attractive got you
but it works that [ __ ]
nft projects are gonna fail at length
but i'm gonna build one of the biggest
ones of all time god damn
v friends
again
friends yes now
is it that they're buying
the little characters or are they really
buying your time both
and only a couple only one percent who
wants the [ __ ] character when they
can have this only one percent you're
gonna talk to them like you talk to
ankur
talk to me nice
you give me enough aetherium
yo what is your only fan's price
listen only fans is just the
acceleration of my hyper thesis on why
the blockchain is going to win nfts are
going to create
things that we can't think of
the internet came along right hardcore
95.96
everybody called it the information
super highway the first you know a lot
almost everybody in this room now is too
young but like i was i remember it i got
through high school without the internet
through high school i didn't know right
so i lived my life before the internet
came along when the internet first hit
everyone's like it's good for
information i was like i'm a terrible
student i don't need to go to the
library anyway it's better than going to
library i'm like i don't go to a library
anyway so it was a [ __ ] yeah then i
started saying wait a minute it's
evolving what's this america online [ __ ]
you could chat age sex location for some
of the 45 year olds you remember that
asl
you know
so
it started to evolve and i remember in
97 telling my friends i'm like i think
people are gonna
people are gonna hook up because you
know because we're in college i'm like
people are gonna hook up through this
thing and like online dating in 2000 as
a brand was a 487 pound dude living in
his mom's basement
when anybody in 2000 said online dating
everyone's like gross yo there was a
stigma to it yeah you guys remember this
yeah like you were embarrassed to say
how you met if you're not 100
and now if you met in person
it's the first per first thing you say
like oh yeah we met old school it was
actually at a bar
yeah
like that's crazy like how you guys know
it's less efficient yeah it doesn't seem
as strategic yeah it seems like a waste
of time
yeah but it's exciting dude yeah it's
it's
exciting if you've got game yeah yeah
and if you don't really not exciting if
you don't but it's more exciting if you
don't
no stakes are that much higher guys that
clip is brought to you by blue chew the
makers of hard dicks and happy wives
that's right your girl deserves it even
your side chick deserves your best and
the way you're gonna deliver it to her
is getting on that chew same active
ingredients inside cialis or viagra but
this is the chew this is the one we rock
with and this is the one that we do
spinal damage to the ones we love with
make sure
you get your first month free by going
to bluechew.com
and use the promo code andrew you just
gotta pay five dollar shipping that's it
thank you so much for watching the clips
keep supporting the podcast we'll see
you soon